do we have any fights coming up in the
UFC Jon Jones Saturday uh-huh oh I know
you had your boy on Dominic Reyes
where's all your money yeah yeah
I love Dom but come on yeah Dom doesn't
have as much experience he's been 513
fights yeah and your girl um Valentina
Shevchenko she's fighting that girl that
you know Katy Chuckie Guillen oh yeah
yeah I love Katy GKN shift shank is the
biggest favorite in the code and the
code rightfully so
yeah just beat the [ __ ] out that girl
she's just a beast and make good luck
mistress see how that pay-per-use gonna
do carny [ __ ] huh cards bad it is it's
bad it's custom fighting No get out
sorry sir sorry but just don't no no but
what is he fighting I've I feel his
Magri there's no hey talk about black
guys yet hey man no come on I'm just
asking show Brown the card quad Adams
and Justin Tavia tava um dan egg and
your Derrick Lewis Latifi low two on the
card enjoy that leti well it's first by
the man in car that's not low I'm in
such a good that's a good way to kick
off a mean of guard oh I'm surprised I
didn't put that third uh-huh it's just a
[ __ ] card though I just don't know
anybody that's you know well you know
John you know of course tommyrot
Shevchenko yeah you know Derrick Lewis
you know of Latifi yeah and really
remember she had the boyfriend with the
Nazi tattoo your buddy we had let's keep
going just you can't just skip over the
head I'm not saying yeah I got a Hitler
bus in my house but that doesn't mean
Hitler Hitler bus ridiculous just his
face right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[ __ ] [ __ ]